okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p here
is a very important voicemail that I
received take a listen to this hey David
I just uh you know I'm tired of hearing
this narrative that Donald Trump isn't
going to debate Bernie because either a
he's scared of Bernie or B he just feels
like he doesn't have to debate Bernie
and I just want to put that to rest
because that would be seating a platform
for Bernie to just say whatever he wants
about Donald Trump to the American
people in a crucial election without
Donald Trump there to say is people for
the American people and I think that
would just be that that would be
devastating to Trump's chances to win in
2020 and he knows it and I'm sure people
on his campaign know it yes so you're
not wrong in general I think the most
likely scenario is Trump will plan to
debate whoever is the eventual
Democratic nominee there's a couple
things there one you're assuming that if
Trump doesn't debate that bernie is just
given 90 minutes to say whatever he
wants and answer questions it would be
unprecedented it would be uncharted
territory that one of the major two
candidates of the two parties says I'm
simply not going to do debates so for me
it's not a guarantee that Bernie just
gets time to do whatever he wants that's
a question mark
the thing that is coming up more and
more is that if you believe that Donald
Trump is declining cognitively there is
a question mark about whether Donald
Trump would be able to handle a
90-minute debate with one other
candidate in August or September or even
October when if you believe Trump is
deteriorating cognitively he would
presumably be more deteriorated again
there's a number of different arguments
I don't think that Trump would not go to
the debates because he's scared of
Bernie I agree with you I think there's
other stories that are taking place and
of course I don't know that you're right
that Trump would suffer even if Bernie
gets to just say what he wants for 90
minutes Trump can win without appealing
to people who like Bernie right I mean
truck Donald Trump lost the popular vote
in 2016 one electoral II he can do it
again just by firing up his own
and saying the debates are rigged I'm
not going is not guaranteed to hurt him
that may actually resonate with enough
of his supporters that he could win
again but you are right the most likely
scenario is Trump shows up at the
debates today on the bonus show we will
talk about the newfound focus on
helicopter safety that has surfaced
since the tragic death of Kobe Bryant we
are also going to talk about a man who
was handcuffed and in a police cruiser
and yet was shot and killed how did that
happen
we will discuss and we will also talk
about another one of these hilarious
wealthy NIMBY not in my backyard type
stories this one is out of Florida all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show don't miss it sign up for a
membership at join pakman.com to get
instant access or become a patron at the
$5 or greater level at patreon.com slash
david pakman show lastly one more
reminder Sunday the David Pakman show
birthday special it's my birthday on
Sunday we're doing a huge membership
blowout if you want to be notified just
get on our newsletter mailing list okay
david pakman.com you'll see a place in
the upper right you type in your email
address and then on sunday you'll get an
email with instructions on how to take
advantage of this discount the emails
are flooding in people concerned that I
will be indicted because the discount is
so huge it could be illegal on the west
coast and we are retaining counsel
though that we I want to do the discount
even if it puts me at risk of prison
time get access to that special by
getting on our mailing list to david
pakman.com talk to you on the bonus show
in mere minutes